et nous accueillir incroyable mais vrai
allain bougrain dubourg président de la
ligue de protection des oiseaux la lp
ont accueilli très amicalement dans une
ferme contre homme qui n'est pourtant
pas en bio plus étonnant encore assis à
la même table dressée dans une grange
voici côte à côte un ponte de
l'assemblée permanente des chambres
d'agriculture et le pourfendeur des
pesticides
en général on s'est un peu la guerre
faut dire les choses on reproche aux
agriculteurs ben les vingt ans le
cortège de pesticides on n'écoute pas
forcément leurs difficultés et là l'idée
c'est de réfléchir ensemble pour trouver
des solutions afin de valoriser la
biodiversité sans impacter la production
ou bien évidemment il peut y avoir des
médecins où il peut y avoir des tensions
mais il faut surtout créer son avenir
notre adn c'est un patrimoine commun que
sont les oiseaux que sont les espaces
agricoles et nous avons trouvé
intéressant ici dans le loir-et-cher de
voir que depuis plusieurs années des
agriculteurs des responsables
d'environnement sont ensemble pour créer
leur avenir en partageant leurs
connaissances et c'est une convention de
partenariat que si ni la lp o et les
chambres d'agriculture pour offrir aux
agriculteurs qui le désirent les
conseils pour changer leur a seulement
pour planter des arbres des ou encore
pour installer des nichoirs pour les
faucons et les chouettes afin qu'ils
éliminent les petits rats des champs
les campagnols et surtout nous évite
d'utiliser la proximité la bromadiolone
et donc
on développe ses techniques alternatives
et d'ailleurs au passage la bromadiolone
nous faisait plus de mal que de bien et
amplifier le phénomène est en fait plus
on utilise ce genre de choses plus on
détruit les prédateurs les écosystèmes
et derrière plus on est plus à une
campagne sommes entrés pêcheurs avaient
pris conseil auprès de la lpo pour
installer ces nichoirs construit par des
élèves d'un institut médico éducatif
le cultivateur du loir-et-cher est donc
le premier à avoir impliqué cette
convention destinée désormais à motiver
et conseiller le plus grand nombre
d'agriculteurs pour introduire de la
biodiversité sur leur exploitation